work on gratitude and the way you work
on gratitude is attention is the number
one asset if writing it down three times
in the morning works well then actually
do it every day not for 2 weeks January
1st to the 13th and then give up like
work is work and if you're unhappy and
you've got some money go to therapy and
if you don't have money go start
listening to more positivity go take a
walk you are accountable you are capable
don't blame your grandma don't blame
your mom blame yourself and don't blame
yourself like I suck and beat yourself
up have compassion to you that this is
my circumstance but I can fix it for
everyone who's listening you have to go
through the work